der tank rabatt war eine schnapsidee zu
der einsicht kommen nicht nur verärgerte
bürger an der zapfsäule sondern auch die
handelnden in der ampelkoalition
und wenn eine nicht so gute idee
schlecht läuft dann muss man helfen so
sagt es robert habeck der
wirtschaftsminister von den grünen hilft
also jetzt dem finanzminister von der
fdp das kartellrecht soll verändert
werden damit mineralölkonzerne weniger
preistreibende absprachen treffen können
3 milliarden kostet der rabatt und der
schritt weiter und um die zwei und
unsozial streit um tank rabatt unser
thema in der phoenix runde
[Musik]
phoenix runde
schönen guten abend ganz herzlich
willkommen aus berlin ich darf meine
gäste vorstellen michael kruse ist bei
uns von der fdp als energiepolitischer
sprecher seiner fraktion und
vorsitzender der liberalen in hamburg
und von dort ist er auch zugeschaltet
dank für die einladung grüße sie und
liebe grüße professor marcel fritsche er
leitet das deutsche institut für
wirtschaftsforschung und ist professor
für makroökonomie an der humboldt
universität zu berlin
herzlich willkommen adrian willig
hauptgeschäftsführer des
wirtschaftsverbandes ntx fuels und
energie und der vertritt
mineralölunternehmen und herzlich
willkommen birgit marschall sie ist
parlamentskorrespondent in der
rheinischen post beginnen wir mit ihnen
herr kruse der tank rabatt jetzt nach
all der aufregung die ist darum gibt
eben auch in der ampelkoalition ist es
eine gute oder eine schlechte idee
gewesen
so auf jeden fall ein richtiges ansinnen
die autofahrerinnen und autofahrer zu
entlasten wir sehen ja dass aufgrund der
steigenden preise auch der staat
mehreinnahmen erzielt und es ist nur
folgerichtig dass der staat hier nicht
als gewinner der krise auftritt sondern
den teil den er mehr einnimmt auch an
die verbraucherinnen und verbraucher
zurück gibt und wir haben ja heute auch
gute zahlen vom ifo-institut gesehen die
gezeigt haben dass ein großteil wenn
nicht sogar alles vom tank rabatt auch
tatsächlich weitergereicht wird insofern
meine ich dass es die richtige
entscheidung gewesen also wer genau
profitiert von diesem tank rabatt
von dem tank rabatt profitieren
diejenigen die mit dem auto fahren und
das ifo-institut hat ja mit seinen
zahlen heute gezeigt dass zwischen 85
und 100 prozent des staatlich gewährten
rabatt weitergegeben werden es ist kein
geheimnis wir als freie demokraten
hätten uns gut vorstellen können dass
weiterhin die preise ausgewiesen werden
an den tankstellen und dann ein direkter
rabatt auch ausgewiesen wird das hätte
den vorteil gehabt dass jeder hätte
sehen können dass auch die volle summe
weitergegeben werden muss das ist in der
koalition jetzt so gewesen dass es da
ein kompromiss gab aber ich freue mich
dass der wirtschaftsminister jetzt auch
noch mal die kartellaufsicht auf den
plan gerufen hat und dabei wollen wir
ihn als freie demokraten natürlich
unterstützen der wirtschaftsminister ist
ja nicht begeistert von der idee sachs
ist schlechte idee half roger und wenn
ich jetzt die zahlen sehen wenn man auf
die statistiken schaut von
benzinpreis.de rädern gab es im
wochendurchschnitt ende mai super zwei
euro 16 diese um die um die zwei euro
und mitte juni kostete beide so zwei
euro das ist doch dann eigentlich nicht
so wie es in dieser ifo studie jetzt
heute gesagt wird dass es zu 100 prozent
weitergegeben wird es schwierig genau
abzuschätzen zu sagen was wäre passiert
wenn es diesen tank rabatt nicht gegeben
hätte das wäre eigentlich die frage um
herauszufinden wie hat sich wirklich
wurde etwas weiter gegeben ich denke es
ist fair zu sagen dass sowohl
mineralölkonzerne davon profitiert haben
aber sicherlich auch ein teil an die
konsumentinnen konsumenten weitergegeben
wurde wir sehen dass vor allem die marge
also das was die mineralölkonzerne
raffinerien pro liter diesel oder benzin
verdient ihr seit dem ersten juli
gestiegen ist und das ist eine klare
indikation jetzt mal bei den längeren
horizont
wir hatten ende januar ein diesel preis
von 1 eur 60 der stieg dann bis ende
märz auf 230 und von diesen 70 euro cent
sind ungefähr 20 bis 25 euro cent durch
höhere importkosten höhere kosten
entstanden und 45 bis 50 cent höhere
margen gewesen also es ist deshalb ein
urteil der höheren preise was die
konsumenten konsumenten zahlen nicht
nach russland gewandert oder im
mittleren osten in der form von höheren
importpreisen sondern auch die
raffinerien und die mineralölkonzerne
haben ordentlich verdient wir als
wissenschaftlerin wissenschaftler haben
auch immer gesagt es handelt sich hier
um ein markt in dem es eben keinen
vollen wettbewerb gibt ja und deshalb
ist es nun mal so dass ein teil dann
auch bei den unternehmen einbehalten
wird und auch deshalb war es nicht
schlecht fragen direkt mal jemand der
die unternehmen vertritt herr willig wie
stark profitieren die unternehmen von
diesem tank rabatt also uns ist bewusst
dass gestiegene kraftstoffpreise
natürlich für viele autofahrerinnen und
autofahrern eine erhebliche belastung
sind aber ich möchte hier klar sagen die
energie steuerabsenkung wird von den
tankstellenunternehmen weitergegeben wir
haben jetzt unabhängig von der zum 16
auf benzin und diesel gesenkten energie
steuer allerdings eine entwicklung
weltweit das die hat mit angebot und
nachfrage zu tun dass aufgrund knapperen
angebot angebots
mineralölunternehmen haben direkt nach
kriegsbeginn begonnen schrittweise aus
russischem öl auszusteigen bei
steigender nachfrage
das hat zu preissteigerungen geführt und
zusätzlich zieht die nachfrage an den
usa und weltweit wir haben also
zusätzlich unabhängig von dieser energie
steuersenkung weltweit steigende
kraftstoffpreise und das führt jetzt
dazu da sie teuer wer während preise
denn wenn jetzt die energie studenten
nicht bekommen naja dann werden sie um
die energie steuer eben teurer und wir
sehen das auch im europäischen vergleich
da sind andere länder haben wir andere
höhere preissteigerungen erlebt
beispielsweise kommen jetzt
autofahrerinnen und autofahrer aus
luxemburg nach deutschland um zu zeigen
oder aus dänemark weil es hier billiger
ist und das zeigt die energie
steuersenkung wird weitergegeben und
nochmal wir haben halt gleichzeitig
effekte weltweit und nicht nur hier in
deutschland die zu höheren
kraftstoffpreisen führen der
bundeswirtschaftsminister sagt aber es
ist das eingetreten wovor viele experten
gewarnt haben die mineralölkonzerne
streichen den profit ein die
verbraucherinnen und verbraucher merken
nichts von der steuersenkung was sagen
sie dazu gut ich halte das für so nicht
nachvollziehbar wir haben also mineral
unternehmen haben auf eigeninitiative
zusammen mit der bundesregierung sofort
nach kriegsbeginn begonnen weniger
russisches öl zu beziehen das heißt da
haben sich schon mal bezugsquellen
verringert das hat sozusagen zu einer
gewissen verknappung geführt und wenn
sie sich gucken jetzt kommen noch
weitere effekte hinzu also die
bevorstehende sommer fahrsaison in usa
also steigende nachfrage und wenn wir
jetzt mal die jüngsten entwicklungen
auch noch mal ansehen vorhin war in den
medien zu sehen haben wir auch in
deutschland probleme zum beispiel güter
zu transportieren es stehen mittlerweile
kesselwagen teilweise einen tag man die
bis zu zwei wochen es kommen jetzt noch
logistische probleme hinzu und andere
herausforderung eines in raffinerien und
zerstört worden sodass also knappere
kapazitäten auf steigende nachfrage
treffen und dafür ist sie zu höheren
preise steigen ja man ist ja die frage
wer von gewinn frau mascher sieht man
mit einzubinden dieser runde wie
sinnvoll oder wie was für eine idee ist
dieser tank rabatt gewesen die
einsamsten total gute idee die andere
sagen es ist eben nicht richtig
schlechte idee die große mehrheit sagt
ja schon dass er nicht gute idee war
weil sie eben auch andere aspekte noch
hat außer dass das dass sie eben nicht
offensichtlich nicht komplett
weitergegeben wurde an die autofahrer
sie ist nämlich ein bisschen unsozial
weil natürlich die menschen die große
autos fahren mit großen motoren auch
mehr tanken und oft sind es eben die
wohlhabenden die die großen autos haben
und deswegen tendenziell hilft als die
synergie steuersenkung menschen mit
höheren einkommen mehr als menschen mit
geringeren einkommen gleichwohl muss man
natürlich sagen alle haben von diesem
tank rabatt profitiert schon alle
autofahrer durch die band aber die die
eben aber nicht als ursprung hinter der
weiterer punkt den ich eben eigentlich
noch gravierender finde ist es ist
unökologisch wir wollen ja eigentlich
gerade erreichen dass menschen weniger
auto fahren oder dass sie mal über den
preiseffekt
nachdenken kommen ob sie nicht mal auf
eine fahrt verzichten können und wir
haben ja gerade diese co2 preis
eingeführt deswegen um die co2
produktion im tendenziell zu verteuern
und jetzt machen wir genau das gegenteil
der staat gibt halt 3 milliarden aus als
unheimlich viel geld ist für nur drei
monate wie dieser tank rabatt andauert
und konterkariert eben seine eigene
maßen maßnahme mit der co2 bepreisung
der große wie sinnvoll ist es drei
milliarden mit drei milliarden sozusagen
einen markt zu subventionieren das ist
doch eigentlich nicht eine politik die
zur fdp passt warum haben sie das
trotzdem gemacht
ja also ich würde gerne meiner forderte
vorrednerin an einer stelle
widersprechen der wesentliche punkt ist
wir geben den menschen ja nicht etwas
was der staat verdient hat sondern wir
nehmen ihnen etwas weniger von dem weg
was sie dafür im moment ausgeben müssen
wenn der benzinpreis steigt dann steigen
automatisch auch die steuereinnahmen mit
deswegen sprach ich vorhin davon dass
der staat an dieser stelle krisen
profiteur ist und ich meine in einer
zeit von sehr stark steigender inflation
sollte der staat nicht noch steuern auf
die steigenden preise mehr einnehmen
sondern diese mehreinnahmen die sollten
wir den menschen in teilen zurück geben
genau das tun wir mit dem tank rabatt
deswegen ist es auch eine sinnvolle
maßnahme aber jetzt aber der punkt sehen
ja nicht entlasten und ja wenn sie wenn
sie sehen wo wir alles entlasten dann
als das ja breit angelegt wir machen das
mit dem neuen euro ticket im nahverkehr
wir machen das mit dem tank rabatt wir
machen das mit dem energie
kostenzuschuss wir machen eine
abmilderung der kalten progression der
grundfreibetrag wird erhöht erstmal über
10.000 euro das heißt wir haben ja
wirklich ein gesamtes maßnahmenpaket ein
teil davon ist der tank rabatt und ich
meine dieses paket das ist sehr sinnvoll
und jetzt sagt herr beck ist eine
schlechte idee aber immer muss jetzt
helfen damit es nicht ganz so schlimm
wird und deshalb versucht der kater
rechtlich etwas zu unternehmen also muss
der grüne wirtschaftsminister jetzt dem
liberalen finanzminister der aus der
patsche helfen was ist das für eine
situation in der ampel da gerade ja zum
glück muss hier niemand irgendwem aus
der patsche helfen ich möchte gerne bei
herrn fratzscher anschließen weil der ja
zu recht darauf hingewiesen hat dass
insbesondere der markt für raffinerien
nicht besonders wettbewerblich geprägt
ist und genau dort müssen wir ansetzen
ich habe das gefühl wir haben langsam
vergessen was hier eigentlich ursache
und was hier wirkung ist die ursache ist
der angriffskrieg putins auf die ukraine
und die folge davon ist unter anderem
dass es im raffineriebereich
verknappungen gibt und ich möchte
deswegen auf den raffinerien markt zu
sprechen kommen weil hier ja mit schwedt
eine der großen raffinerien die ganz
ostdeutschland fast versorgt ihn nach
wie vor in russischer mehrheit
beteiligung ist und das bedeutet
diejenigen die kein interesse daran
haben dass die energiepreise in
westeuropa niedrig sind die sind immer
noch in diesem markt beteiligt und
deswegen meine ich wir müssen den
wettbewerb stärken und das stimme ich
dem mit dem wirtschaftsminister
vollkommen überein und wir müssen dafür
sorgen dass diejenigen die kritische
infrastruktur in deutschland gegen
unsere interessen missbrauchen nicht
mehr eigentümer dieser kritischen
infrastruktur sein können was man
natürlich sagen dass greift ja erst mit
einiger verzögerung also dass es bis das
wettbewerbsrecht reformiert ist also
nicht sogar das merken würden an der
zahl da würde das ja lange dauern
doch man möchte gerne ich würde gerne
noch einmal zu diesem aspekt etwas sagen
denn in der tat ist es so wir haben das
energie sicherungs gesetz vor einem
monat deutsch durch den deutschen
bundestag gebracht und das deutlich
verschärft es ist jetzt möglich in der
kritischen infrastruktur sehr schnell
einzugreifen wir haben
eingriffsmöglichkeiten mit dem energie
sicherungs gesetz geschafft wir müssen
nicht erst neue kartellrechtliche
regelungen auf den weg bringen wie der
wirtschaftsminister gestern an
diskutiert hat sondern er hat die
instrumente an der hand dafür zu sorgen
dass starten die unternehmen
kontrollieren die gegen die deutschen
und europäischen interessen im in der
kritischen infrastruktur agieren dass
wir diese staaten auch aus diesen
beteiligungen rausdrängen könnten kommen
damals zu dir zu den sachen die wird
wirtschaftsminister habe jetzt vorhat
frage wie sinnvoll ist dass ich sehe
jetzt sagt ja aber so funktioniert es
nicht wir müssen auf eine andere art
dafür sorgen dass es eben diese
absprache nicht gibt oder wie
funktioniert das überhaupt nicht könnte
das jetzt noch mal erklären na ja die
idee ist dass das bundeskartellamt sich
jetzt anschaut gibt es dort
möglicherweise absprachen oder irgend
ein illegales verhalten und wenn das
nachgewiesen werden könnte wer als
erstes zu spät um noch wirklich frist am
tank rabatt zu ändern zweitens könnte es
dann zu strafen kommen mein persönliches
gefühl des überzeugung ist dass man dass
es dort keine preisabsprachen gibt also
kein illegales verhalten es ist einfach
in der natur der sache wenn sie einen
markt haben wo einige wenige konzerne
den markt unter sich ausmachen völlig
wissen auch wie die anderen die preise
setzen dann ist es natürlich so dass
wenn sie steuer veränderung machen so
wie jetzt ein tank rabatt dass ein
großer teil dieses standplatz in den
taschen der mineralölkonzerne landet und
nicht der verbraucherinnen und
verbraucher das ist nun mal das ist kein
spezifikum jetzt für den markt für für
den benzin oder diesel sondern das ist
in fast allen märkten so wenig
wettbewerb gibt und ich will noch mal
ein punkt sagen für mich ist diese
politik diese tank rabatt zirkus oder
muss ich ihnen widersprechen
eine höchst antiliberale politik denn
hier haben sie ein staat der den
menschen vor gibt wofür sie das geld zu
benutzen haben und eine viel bessere
politik wäre dass man die drei
milliarden euro nimmt den menschen das
geld in tasche gibt sagt hier über eine
energie pauschale oder energie geld
haben sie das geld und jeder einzelne
mensch kann selber entscheiden was er
mit dem geld machen möchte das fahrrad
kauft oder nicht sondern auch das sind
um zur arbeit zu kommen aber viele leute
können umsteigen das ist was frau merkel
gesagt hat wir müssen weniger fossile
energieträger nutzen das ist teil wie
wir mit dem krieg umgehen können wir
müssen weniger verbrauchen und auch um
den klimawandel zu gestalten und da ist
eine solche politik wie der tank rabatt
in jeglicher hinsicht nicht nur unsozial
sondern kontraproduktiv und der richtige
für die das würde ich mir auch jetzt
schon dass die chinesen haben oder das
sagen stopp sagt hier sind die drei
milliarden euro wir geben den menschen
das und lassen die menschen selber
entscheiden wofür sie das geld bauen
hellweg aus ihrer sicht wie sozial ist
dieser tank rabatt also ich möchte gerne
vielleicht ein zwei dinge besprechen ist
weiß hier mehrere themen angesprochen
zunächst einmal das ist das primat der
politik sich entlastungsmaßnahmen zu
überlegen wir als verband und unsere
unternehmen setzen diese energie
steuersenkung um und zwar heute noch mal
vom ifo institut in münchen sie haben es
gesagt herr kruse die wird
vollumfänglich umgesetzt so wenn wir der
zweite punkt sie sprachen jetzt einzelne
raffinerien an ich wollte noch mal
darauf zurückkommen das sozusagen
viele unserer mitgliedsunternehmen mit
beginn des krieges
eigeninitiativ zusammen mit der
bundesregierung gesagt haben wie kommen
wir jetzt bis jahresende möglichst raus
aus russischem öl das sind gewaltige
herausforderungen und damit fallen
bezugsquellen weg und diese knappheit
verknüpft mit einer gestiegenen
nachfrage hat zu höheren preisen geführt
das ist weniger ein thema einer
einzelnen raffinerie sondern viele
unternehmen haben gesagt sie steigen aus
und wenn wir uns nochmal die thematik
angucken wenn wir darüber sprechen
welche maßnahmen sind vielleicht
geeignet und so weiter dann ist es geht
es einerseits darum wie können wir
betroffene entlasten darüber haben wir
gesprochen und ich möchte das aufgreifen
was sie angesprochen haben professor
fritsche es geht ja auch darum wie wir
zur klimaneutralität kommen und da
möchte ich sagen unser verband ntx
wirtschaftsverband fuß und energie wir
begleiten die heutige
mineralölwirtschaft auf dem weg dieser
transformation denn es regnet der
transformation macht es dann in einen
tank rabatt zu geben das ist also frei
sein sie haben vollkommen recht es geht
darum wie wir schrittweise von fossilen
energieträgern loskommen hin zu
erneuerbaren unsere mitgliedsunternehmen
möchten investieren in den markthochlauf
von treibhausgas neutralen wasserstoff
sie bauen ladeinfrastruktur auf sie
stellen treibhausgas neutrale produkte
für die chemische industrie her sie
investieren in alternative kraftstoffe
und da ist es natürlich klug zu gucken
beispielsweise wie können sich eine
energiebesteuerung ich nenne ihnen ein
beispiel aber jetzt dermaßen umgestalten
dass eben ein treibhausgas neutraler
kraftstoff quasi kaum besteuert wird und
ein fossiler höher besteuert wird dh
im moment an der tanksäule haben wir
noch mal bei sich eine einseitige
debatte denn wir wollen ja auch diese
transformation hinkriegen und deswegen
müssen
maßnahmen auch geeignet sein diesen weg
hin zu kriegen und vielleicht noch einen
punkt es ist noch gar nicht so lange her
da haben die gleich jetzt sagen benzin
müsste viel viel billiger werden gesagt
fossile energieträger sollten noch viel
teurer werden also dass
man aus dem internet ist ja schon
ziemlich teuer frau merkel also bleiben
wir noch mal bei den menschen die jetzt
dieses aufs auto angewiesen sind die
pendeln müssen diese jetzt sagen das ist
einfach nicht gerecht da der spritpreis
ist immer noch so hoch und es sind eben
nicht 30 30 cent weniger als vor dem
ersten juni also war wie soll man damit
umgehen wie das wäre wirklich sinnvoller
als das was wir jetzt haben also wir
haben ja auch schon für die autofahrer
was getan das darf nicht verschweigen
die pendlerpauschale oder die für die
fernpendler die pendlerpauschale wird
deutlich erhöht und zwar rückwirkend zum
ersten januar also man kann jetzt nicht
sagen vor dem entlastungspaket dass noch
nichts für autofahrer getan wurde ja ich
denke wir müssen tatsächlich mehr tun
mehr anreize schaffen um den menschen
ein ökologisches verhalten zu
ermöglichen also tatsächlich den
öffentlichen nahverkehr massiv ausbauen
ich weiß dass das bei der bahn natürlich
nicht schnitt so schnell geht aber man
kann zum beispiel schneller buslinien
einrichten und und man sollte auch
wieder fahrgemeinschaften bilden also
man sollte einfach anreize schaffen
damit menschen diesen teuren
benzinpreise noch ausweichen können und
ich würde ganz gerne aber auch noch mal
was sagen zu der verachtung auf dem
gesamten markt es ist ja so dass die
mineralkonzerne eben auch doch zum
großteil die raffinerien besitzen und
wir dadurch eben und die tankstellen und
das tankstellennetz und dadurch haben
wir so eine sogenannte vertikale
konzentration und die muss entflochten
werden und
auf dem richtigen weg also ich bin
ehrlich gesagt dafür das tankstellennetz
abzuspalten von den mineralölkonzernen
das werden sie natürlich nicht gerne
hören aber er hätte den vorteil dass die
mineralölkonzerne nicht durchregieren
können sozusagen von der raffinerie oder
von der ölproduktion zur raffinerie und
dann bis hin zu den tankstellen
dass das eben dass der wettbewerb
gestärkt wird und dass zum beispiel eine
aral-tankstelle dann auch bei shell öl
einkaufen könnte also das dass man nicht
immer nur sein eigenes öl vertreibt
sondern das dann eben auch wettbewerb
beim benzin entsteht also das wort
durchregieren ist mir etwas zu einfach
natürlich ist es richtig dass einige
unternehmen zb in der rohölförderung
tätig sind sie betreiben raffinerien und
sie betreiben auch tankstellen übrigens
in deutschland ist die zahl der
unternehmen die raffinerien betreiben
ohne tankstellen die ist gestiegen in
den letzten jahren das ist nur ein
aspekt es gibt also solche und solche
unternehmen und ich kann nicht erkennen
warum es nicht möglich sein soll dass
ein unternehmen was rohöl fördert und
verarbeitet was es dann auf einer
öffentlichen plattform für alle
beteiligten zu einem marktpreis verkauft
auch nicht auch eine raffinerie
betreiben darf um dann dort benzin oder
diesel für alle öffentlich zu
marktpreisen an freie tankstellen an
wettbewerber an verschiedene zu gleichen
konditionen zu verkaufen und wenn es
jetzt darum geht und so haben wir die
überlegungen der jüngsten tage
verstanden zu sagen auch ohne dass
verstöße
nachgewiesen werden
beabsichtigt man oder hat man
überlegungen jetzt
übermäßige sogenannte gewinne
abzuschöpfen quasi nach eigenem ermessen
oder firmen zerschlagen zu können ohne
dass es dafür wirklich verstöße gibt das
halten wir für sehr problematisch das
halten wir auch für unangemessen es ist
auch rechtlich einigermaßen
problematisch und fragen richtig stehen
vielleicht noch einen dritten punkt
ich mache mir dann schon auch sorgen
über den wirtschaftsstandort deutschland
wenn jetzt eine firma die beispielsweise
die transformation investieren möchte
die neue technologien machte jetzt
ständig damit rechnen muss es kommt
jetzt irgendein eingriff wohlgemerkt
ohne dass es nachgewiesene verstöße gibt
darum geht es ja sie haben vorhin gesagt
sie sind die gewinne gestiegen in den
letzten monaten oder nicht also firmen
firmen die machen natürlich haben firmen
höhere einnahmen das gibt es ja in
vielen sektoren es geht aber doch jetzt
darum kann irgendjemand
festlegen diese gewinne einer firma oder
jene die sind jetzt aus irgend einem
grund nicht nicht koscher und sie haben
gesagt das möchte vielleicht noch eines
sagen herr professor fratzscher das
kartellamt schaut hin ob es verstöße
gibt oder ob es unregelmäßigkeiten gibt
und das finden wir richtig das ist auch
die aufgabe eines kartellamts aber was
wir für sehr problematisch hält ist
jetzt sozusagen nach eigenem ermessen
und kriterien die keiner kennt
anzufangen
von firmen etwas abzuspalten und so
weiter und das schauen wir doch mal ein
bisschen genauer hin es ist glaube ich
dass er
in einer debatte gerne noch mal eingehen
wenn das für sie noch genau ich wollte
ihnen gerade das wort geben also die
frage nach der nach der entflechtung und
die frage auch dann dass wir mal zu
diesem thema über gewinnen steuer kommen
also wenn die konzerne so viel mehr
gewinn machen wie sinnvoll ist es dann
dass sie dann auch etwas mehr steuern
zahlen ja ich würde gerne vorhaben noch
auf zwei aspekte eingehen wenn sie mir
erlauben das erste ist ich hatte es ja
in meinem beitrag vorhin schon versucht
und ich werde das jetzt noch einmal tun
die debatte die in den letzten fünf
minuten geführt wurde es eine über
jahrzehnte in deutschland geführt worden
ist und ich als liberaler wettbewerbs
ökonom bin der meinung überall dort wo
marktmacht missbraucht wird da muss auch
ein starker staat eingreifen der als
hüter des wettbewerbs dann auch dafür
sorgt dass mag macht abgebaut wird und
wettbewerben fünf stich funktioniert das
ist für mich vollkommen klar ich möchte
aber noch einmal darauf hinweisen die
situation in der realität in den
raffinerien in deutschland ist eine die
abweicht von dem was in den letzten
jahren und jahrzehnten hier schon
diskutiert wurde wir haben raffinerien
die sind im russischen mehrheitsbesitz
das ist ein großes problem denn diese
raffinerien da hat der
mehrheitseigentümer kein interesse daran
dass der dahinter liegende markt von
tankstellen usw
funktioniert wir haben raffinerien da
sind großen minderheits beteiligt in
diesen raffinerien wird das russische öl
schon jetzt nicht abgekauft denn wir
haben zwar noch kein embargo aber zum
glück viele unternehmen und kunden in
deutschland die sagen wir kaufen kein
russisches öl mehr in diesen raffinerien
funktioniert die produktion teilweise
schon nur noch eingeschränkt weil das
russische öl die raffinerien quasi
verstopft das sind konkrete probleme die
wir haben in diesem ohnehin schon
wettbewerbs technisch eingeschränkten
markt an diese probleme müssen wir
dringend dran denn dann wird hier auch
der wettbewerb gilt das war der erste
machen
also herr cruise ich stimme ihnen zu
hundert prozent zu das ist seit vielen
jahren bekannt dass wir einen markt
haben denn nicht wirklich funktioniert
wer zu wenig wettbewerb haben und
letztlich auch ausländische interessen
die gar kein interesse daran haben dass
die preise sinken
wie kann man dann sehenden auges dort
ein tank rabatt reingeben wohl wissend
dass eben vor allem diese konzerne die
sich seit vielen jahren so verhalten
inklusive russischer konzerne davon
profitieren da besteht für mich der
widerspruch mann ist sehenden auges in
diesen fehler reingelaufen ein tank
rabatt zu machen wohl wissend dass ein
großer teil davon eben nicht bei den
konsumenten konsumenten ankommt
das behaupten sondern haben jahr zahlen
ich glaube sie hat institut die zeigen
dass 85 bis 100 prozentig ganzes
weitergeschrieben werden aber nehmen sie
doch einfach mal alternative zahlen auf
den tisch anstatt also wenn sie es hier
einfach nur bei aber warum sagt an der
worldwide moment immer ganz kurz warum
sagte der wirtschaftsminister die ersten
datensätze des bundeskartellamts zeigen
dass die abstände zwischen rohöl und
tagen stellen preisen seit monatsbeginn
stark gestiegen sind und dass er nicht
ihnen auch nicht sagen vielleicht hat
ihm das eingeflüstert dann könnte er uns
die zahlen ja zur verfügung stellen
steht ich habe liefen die fans sind
wirklich ich habe die vom ifo institut
heute gesehen 85 bis 100 prozent werden
weitergegeben aber das
für denjenigen einer tankstelle ist der
hat nicht den eindruck dass die sachen
jetzt 30 cent waren ganz genau der
rohölpreis ist ja weiter gestiegen das
ist bekannt der euro-schwäche gegenüber
dem dollar rohöl wird in dollar
gehandelt das ist auch bekannt dass sind
alles effekte die dazu führen dass
weltweit die preise weiter steigen es
ist darauf hingewiesen worden aus der
schweiz aus dänemark aus luxemburg
kommen die menschen zum tanken nach
deutschland weil es hier jetzt billiger
ist als in luxemburg
ich glaube das haben wir hier alle in
der runde noch nicht erlebt und deswegen
der punkt herr frau und ich wir haben
ein etwas unterschiedliches verständnis
davon wem das geld gehört wenn ich
wesentlich mehr fürs tanken ausgeben
muss und der staat daran wesentlich mehr
an einnahmen erzielt und der staat dann
einen kleinen teil dieser mehreinnahmen
an die menschen zurück gibt dann ist es
nicht der staat der hier geld verteilt
und der eine lenkungswirkung erzielen
müsste sondern dann ist es das geld der
menschen was die viele menschen die
nicht so viele sind nicht so ein hohes
einkommen haben aber autofahren müssen
was diese menschen verdient haben und
denen nehmen wir gerade mehr aus der
tasche und deswegen hat sich die
regierung dafür entschieden ihn ein
bisschen davon zurückzugeben und das
meine ich ist ein richtiges instrument
geworden
als er da waren ja da im letzter aspekt
daran diejenigen die kurzfristig
umsteigen können zum beispiel auf den
nahverkehr die haben jetzt mit dem neuen
euro ticket parallel dazu die chance
ihres lebens ihre kosten richtig zu
drücken und glauben sie mir wenn sie
kosten bewusst sind und einen guten
nahverkehr vor der tür haben dann nehmen
sie das neue nur viele menschen sind auf
das auto angewiesen und die verdienen
nicht so viel geld und deswegen ist es
nur fair dann dafür zu sorgen dass der
staat auch kurzfristig die preise senkt
letzter als da nicht der moment der
größten
vorhin aus meiner sicht als es darum
ging es gebe zu viele unternehmen die
gleichzeitig raffinerien betreiben und
tankstellen dann brachten sie ja kruse
das beispiel einer raffinerie in
ostdeutschland das ist zum beispiel ein
beispiel da ist das nicht der fall da
trifft das schon gar nicht zu dass die
autos
nach deutschland gehört die haben gar
keine tankstellen punkt 1.2 sie haben es
richtig besteht beschrieben das
unternehmen in deutschland begonnen
haben schrittweise auf russisches öl zu
verzichten und das das natürlich dazu
führt dass die bezugsquellen knapper
werden und das sorgt für steigende
preise
ich finde es auch jetzt sozusagen etwas
komisch dass diese eigeninitiative die
ja unmittelbar nach kriegsbeginn na ja
doch das war sogar vor einem öl embargos
und beginnen können wir hätten früher
haben die unternehmen gesagt wir machen
das wir steigen schrittweise aus es gibt
unternehmen die haben 20 milliarden
abschreibung weil sie aus russland
rausgegangen sind und das führt dazu und
deswegen ist das jetzt keine
besonderheit dieser einen raffinerien
sondern das ist der vorteil der punkt
haben sie eben gesagt steigen die
gewinne der konzerne und das ist das was
viele bürger nicht gut nachvollziehen
können frau mascher sie wollten glaub
ich dazu noch mal was a wie wie gehen
wir damit um also wenn wir da was ist
jetzt wenn wir auch die frage stellen
was ist jetzt sozial gerecht oder was es
überhaupt gerecht und wir sehen die die
gewinne steigen gibt es forderungen zum
beispiel von den grünen die sagen da
muss es eine über gewinn steuer geben
jetzt erstmal die frage was ist dein
über gewinnen aber das ganz genauso das
ist schon ein ganz merkwürdiges ein wort
also ich habe das vorher noch nie gehört
es ist
eine sache die nicht gut in die
marktwirtschaft passt also ich glaube da
sollte man sofort von abstand nehmen von
dem gedanken kennen ja da heißt kann
sein ich aber trotzdem ist es das was
nicht in die soziale marktwirtschaft
passt weil der staat dann auf einmal
willkürlich definiert da und da ist ein
über gewinnen den schöpfe ich jetzt mal
ab das schreckt ja jedes unternehmen
abgeben investor niemand weiß mehr wie
viel darf ich eigentlich hier verdienen
und wie wird denn bemessen was eben der
über gewinn ist usw also insofern finde
ich jetzt die
wollte die herr habe gemacht hat
aufgrund der ablehnung der fdp also die
fdp hat ja strikt gesagt die über gewinn
steuer kommt nicht die soll nicht kommen
dann hat herr haben jetzt gesagt okay
modernisiere ich jetzt das kartellrecht
und das ist dann eben auch die bessere
lösung also wenn man das beides
gegeneinander abwägt darf ich auch noch
mal zwei punkte ich wollte noch mal
sagen wenn wir mal gucken was vor dem
ersten juni passiert ist da sind nämlich
die benzinpreise nach oben gegangen und
dann hat man sich sozusagen schon
vorbereitet auf den tank rabatt um dann
eben zu sagen jetzt senken wir um 20
cent den benzinpreis und dann ist man
aber wieder da gelandet wo man gerne
sowieso gewesen wäre weil man eben ja
vorher schon die preise erhöht hat und
da konnte man sehr gut sehen wie eben
dieses kartell das eben ein kartell ist
das aber nicht nachgewiesen werden kann
weil es tatsächlich wahrscheinlich keine
preisabsprachen gibt aber es eben
unsichtbar sage ich mal funktioniert
weil man weil die preise an den
tankstellen sind ja total transparent
die kann man sich auf der handy app
jederzeit angucken auch als verbraucher
also so da hat man gesehen wie eben
dieses kartell funktioniert und man
sieht es ja auch wenn ferien anfangen
dann gehen die preise kollektiv ohne die
übliche morgens tage oder abends barea
und dass man darüber eigentlich auch ja
und es ist halt einfach ein ärgernis
muss man einfach sagen aber format wenn
das zu sagen darf diese behauptung die
können sie doch nicht einfach aufstellen
quasi hier zu sagen man hätte quasi
künstlich sich abgesprochen und preise
zu erhöhen also wir haben wirklich eine
außerordentliche parksituation wir haben
krieg in der ukraine wir haben jetzt
gestiegene nachfrage wir haben jetzt
noch probleme in den lieferketten die
hinzu kommt und das führt dazu dass bei
einer steigenden nachfrage auch preise
steigen also behauptete er dass das was
unabhängig vom krieg ist also eine
marktsituation die jetzt gar nicht mit
dem krieg zu tun hat das sagen sie aber
in fünf jahrzehnten erleben das
gemeinschaftlich preise erhöht und
gesenkt da waren sie einfach so und
unser punkt ist dass die spritpreise
teurer werden oder wenn sie morgens
teurer sind als abends da kann es ja
keinen also da gibt es ja keinen keinen
keinen wirklichen grund führen also das
sagen sie du so das sei es führt
sozusagen gemeinschaftlich mehr oder
weniger so entschieden oder gemacht
worden und ich möchte noch mal darauf
hinaus gehen dass man sagt okay deswegen
gibt es jetzt auch eine
sektoruntersuchung das kartellamt hat ja
eine sektoruntersuchung auch eingeleitet
und mir geht es darum dass man diese
ergebnisse doch jetzt bitteschön mal
abwartet und guckt hat es irgendwelche
dinge gegeben die aus sicht der
kartellbehörden nicht korrekt sind und
dass man dann schlüsse zieht und jetzt
vorweg zu sagen ich möchte quasi frei
entscheiden können ohne dass es
nachweise für verstöße gibt
irgendwelche gewinne wo wir gerade
gesagt haben die man auch gar nicht
definieren kann abzuschöpfen oder firmen
zu zerschlagen
das problematisch vielleicht noch einen
punkt zu gewinnen
generell hatte den gebilden gewinnen da
wär mir noch wichtig das ist eben ein
weiterer aspekt wir haben gerade davon
gesprochen dass wir für uns vor einer
großen transformation befinden wir
wollen klimaneutral werden und auch vor
diesem hintergrund wo firmen jetzt in
neue technologien investieren wollen in
grünen wasserstoff in treibhausgas
neutralen wasserstoff in alternative
kraftstoffe in lahde sollen das stelle
ich mir schon die frage was es bedeutet
wenn eine firma jetzt immer da rechnen
muss ist würde teile nach welchen
kriterien man braucht die wiederum dann
zu investieren in ihrer sorge man die
ganzen namen in richtung
klimaneutralität zu kommen dann die
frage ob man das so auch dann genutzt
wird herr fragt was sagen sie zu dieser
über gewinn steuer macht das sinn wenn
man sagt dass die mineralölkonzerne sind
sozusagen die kriegsgewinnler genau wie
rüstungsfirmen dem sollen jetzt einfach
mal mehr zahlen
ja so einen schritt zurückgehen damals
zur inflation kommt es im großen bild
inflation ist kein schwarzes loch
sondern da zahlen einige mehr und andere
profitieren davon und die profiteure
sind nicht nur herr putin sondern sind
in dem fall auch die mineralölkonzerne
die eben ihre gewinne deutlich nach oben
gefahren haben
und aufgabe des staates ist jack rose
auch nochmal auf ihren punkt zurück zu
kommen ist es einen ausgleich zu
schaffen zu sagen wir müssen die last
die in dieser inflation dieser krise
entsteht auf alle schultern verteilen
und das heißt die die gewinnen durch den
krieg das muss jetzt gar nicht also ich
werde da überhaupt kein vorwurf das
mineral konstant ihr preisabsprachen
aber sie gehören zu den gewinnern und
das ist aufgabe des staates diese lasten
gleich zu verteilen und jetzt zum
begriff über gewinnen ich mag den
begriff auch nicht aber ich glaube der
unterschied der auch von manchen in der
politik fälschlicherweise gemacht wird
bei und tag mit dem mineralölkonzern zu
vergleichen zu sagen bayern hat mit dem
impfstoff auch riesige gewinne gemacht
wie man den jetzt die nicht kennen doch
den will man den können aber die an eine
leistung dafür erbracht haben innovation
dafür erbracht und das was wir jetzt
sehen mit den gewinnen zum beispiel von
mineral konzern ist nicht die leistung
was diese konzerne erbracht haben und da
ist es dann schon die aufgabe zu sagen
wie kann ich für den staat wie kann ich
um verteilen möchte noch einen punkt
machen der mir wichtig ist auch noch mal
zu zu den investitionen dass sie sagen
herr will ich liberal und konzerne
brauchen die gewinne um die zukunft zu
investieren
fossile energieträger in deutschland
werden jedes jahr mit 65 milliarden euro
subventioniert schon jetzt das heißt das
was fossile energieträger an schaden an
umwelt und klima an gesundheit
verursachen wird nicht durch den preis
getragen und dazu sagen man muss jetzt
aber mal ordentlich gewinne machen indem
er alle wirtschaft um die transformation
zu gestalten halte ich für falsch uns
erst einmal die subventionen abbauen
denn nur so kann klimaschutz
gelingt nur so kann auch fairer
wettbewerb bestehen und das ist mein
kritikpunkt dass wir fossile
energieträger sind zu günstig weil sie
nicht den schaden wieder spielen sie
verursachen und die gewinne die jetzt
die mineralölkonzerne machen das ist
kein fehlverhalten davon bin ich
überzeugt aber es ist letztlich das
resultat davon von einem krieg nicht von
einer leistung der mineralölkonzerne
und deshalb sie schon als legitim an für
den staat zu sagen wie kann man die last
auf alle schultern gleich verteilen die
last vorteil einerseits klima klimaziele
erreichen dazu noch gerne an kruse auch
wenn man jetzt hat die fdp wollte den
tankwart die grünen wollten dass man ein
euro ticket spd-chefin es gesagt aber
wir brauchen jetzt ein tempolimit also
da hat man das gefühl da ist so ein
bisschen der gemischtwarenladen der
ampel koalition für jeden irgendwie ein
bisschen ist das die richtige strategie
um damit also mit dem problem was wir
jetzt haben den energiepreisen umzugehen
ja es ist die richtige strategie an sehr
vielen stellen entlastungen
herbeizuführen
es ist auch kein gemischtwarenladen
sondern wir sind in einer koalition wir
haben koalition vorliegen also wir haben
eine koalition geführt wir sind nicht
miteinander fusioniert als drei
unterschiedliche parteien und wenn das
hier und da auch mal deutlich wird dann
wird das die menschen in diesem land
glaube ich eher beruhigen als boden
ruhigen ich würde herrn fratzscher gern
an einer stelle jetzt zuletzt
zustimmen denn er hat ja einmal darauf
hingewiesen dass es notwendig ist dass
wir die transformation im energiebereich
jetzt auch beschleunigung und ich bin
ehrlich gesagt fast zu spät gekommen
jetzt hier im studio weil wir den ganzen
tag im moment das erneuerbare energien
gesetz verhandeln und die größte reform
die es in diesem bereich je gegeben hat
wir wollen die erneuerbaren in den
wettbewerb überführen wir wollen die
rahmenbedingungen so setzen dass die
erneuerbaren in den nächsten jahren so
schnell ausgebaut werden wie es in
diesem land noch nie der fall war und
genau das gibt den menschen in diesem
land dann auch die möglichkeit zu guten
konditionen zu guten preisen auch auf
erneuerbare zu setzen und damit die über
die brücke in die zukunft zu gehen nur
der hinweis sei dann auch erlaubt wird
dürfen diese brücke nicht abreißen bevor
die menschen drüber gegangen sind wenn
sie beruflich auf das auto angewiesen
sind dann müssen sie vielleicht 20 30 40
kilometer am tag fahren dann nützt es
ihnen überhaupt nichts wenn die politik
den ganzen tag über wasserstoff
debattiert denn davon haben sie nichts
sie brauchen dann schon ein angebot das
auch als alternative da ist diese
angebote schnell zu entwickeln und dann
auch in
das unternehmen dann auch diese angebote
großflächig zur verfügung stellen das
ist sozusagen die aufgabe die wir als
ampel haben und glauben 20 jahre werden
sie auch gerecht ja wissen ist jetzt
meine erste legislaturperiode im
bundestag da brauchen sie mir nicht
vorwerfen dass ich das vor 20 jahren
hätte machen
schule gegangen
widersprechen wenn ich finde schon dass
das ein gemischtwarenladen ist das ist
ein sammelsurium von maßnahmen von
einzelmaßnahmen wo die tatsächlich jede
partei hat iris bekommen und das ist für
mich keine strategie wie man eben mit
steigenden energiepreisen umgeht und wie
ich schon gesagt habe ich finde es
müsste der staat müsste die bürger den
bürgern helfen sich anzupassen an die
situation und eben könnte diese dieses
momentum das dass sie eben durch diesen
krieg jetzt auch entstanden ist auch
nutzen um den wandel hin zum zum
klimaschutz und zur transformation zum
veränderten verhalten hin zu bekommen
denn dann sinne wäre das neuron blicke
dann richtig dass also das insofern wäre
das 99 euro tickets gegriffen richtig
aber insgesamt wird er jetzt irgendwie
keine strategie daraus sondern das also
wenn etwas aus einem guss wäre dann
hätte man eben mehr getan um eben diese
transformation auch gleichzeitig zu
verbessern wir bilden ja aber die kalte
progression ab wir haben den
grundfreibetrag das müssen sie erstmal
durch gewerbesteuer verlauf angepasst ja
selbstverständlich das ist doch schon
teil das entlastungspaket halt alles
passen und der energiepreis der
energiepreis pauschal das sind ja alles
das sind ja alles maßnahmen die wir in
einem entlastungspaket schon
herbeigeführt haben herr freytag hat zu
recht die inflation angesprochen wir
sorgen jetzt als erstes dafür dass den
menschen wieder mehr von ihrem
erarbeiteten geld verbleibt das zweite
ist der staat muss sich ein bisschen
zurücknehmen denn auch erst im moment
ral bei der inflation und darüber sorgen
wir dann auch dafür dass die menschen
wieder die möglichen spielräume haben um
auch eine solche transformation ganz
bewusst mit zu begleiten und selbst
vorzunehmen für sich die frage ist eben
wie viel der staat da leisten kann und
ob man nicht ob es nicht einen punkt
gibt wo man sagt da
da müssen wir alle sozusagen kürzer
treten herr willig wann werden die
preise günstiger wieder eine tanke ja
jetzt schon überlegen ob sie in diesem
sommer im urlaub fahren können also ein
blick in die glaskugel kann kann niemand
machen die preise hängt von sehr sehr
vielen faktoren ab wir haben einen einen
krieg in der ukraine wir haben jetzt
herausforderungen in der logistik wir
haben knapp alten raffinerien sind
kaputt es hängt von sehr vielen faktoren
ab und ich bin kein hellseher und kann
ihnen das nicht voraussagen was ich aber
weiß ist dass wir nicht vorschnelle
schlüsse machen sollen ohne zu gucken
gibt es tatsächlich missbräuchliches
verhalten
september wurden diese das für
problematisch und und unangemessen und
was gerade noch mal gesagt wurde von
herrn kruse das unterstützen wir brauen
geeignete rahmenbedingungen für den
marktdruck lauf von neuen technologien
sie haben das beispiel eeg-umlage
absenkung genannt es ist zum beispiel
nur ein letztes beispiel sehr wichtig zu
gucken dass man die bezugs kriterien für
erneuerbaren strom den man für die
herstellung von wasserstoff benötigt
jetzt nicht so krass wieder reguliert
dass dieser markthochlauf gar nicht
entsteht und dann sitzt man fünf jahren
wieder hier warum ist
die menschen überlegen sich jetzt auch
das wie sie in den sommerurlaub fahren
und was ab dem ersten september passiert
der vater was denken sie dann wenn ab
dem ersten september
es sind ja ist ja dieser tank rabatt
vorbei oder sollte man ihnen vorher
schon ein stamm ich finde man es war ein
tank rabatt war ein fehler dann hätte
ich nicht machen sollen aus den punkten
wie wir eben diskutiert haben sind
mitnahmeeffekte es kommt nicht bei den
richtigen menschen dann es ist zu höchst
unsozial und es ist ökologisch unsinnig
deshalb wieso jetzt drei milliarden euro
weiter den falschen geben man kann diese
drei milliarden euro das ist nicht wenig
geld besser nutzen und nochmals der
beste weg aus ökonomischer sicht ist
wirklich den menschen geld in die tasche
zu geben und wir haben immer wieder
entscheidend weil sie selber entscheiden
immer überein die pauschale also ein
direkter transfer tja manche braucht das
auto zum die um zur arbeit zu fahren da
brauche es nicht gibt ja auch jetzt
energie geld aber das kriegen zum
beispiel die rentnerin und das ist das
große problem ist
löcherig viele rentnerinnen rentner
viele menschen mit wenig einkommen
fallen hinten runter und das
entlastungspaket reichen nicht aus wenn
sie die unteren 20 prozent der
geringsten einkommen anschauen davon
bekommen viele haben eine viel höhere
inflation persönlich weil sie andere
dinge konsumieren mehr energie und mehr
nahrungsmittel relativ zum einkommen und
die menschen erhalten nicht genug
unterstützung deshalb denke ich muss es
da eine nachbesserung beim
leistungspakete aber bitte nicht beim
sprit frau marsha gibt ja vorher rettern
krabat noch ganz kurz das wird er nicht
er ist glaube ich nicht so er wird er
vielleicht noch verlängert sodass aber
ich habe jetzt das entsprechend das noch
nicht gehört also aber weil tatsächlich
am ersten september kommt ja das böse
erwachen was passiert dann ist ja also
auch das neue euro ticket vorbei und
dann dann werden die leute sicherlich
eine anschlusslösung erwarten genau
darüber diskutieren wir dann spätestens
am ersten september wieder in der phönix
bochum spielen dessen frau maria kruse
nach hamburg und henrik und vielen dank
ihnen fürs zuschauen morgen sind wir
natürlich wieder für sie da dann schauen
wir noch mal in die ukraine kampf um den
don bass was hilft der ukraine fragen
wir dann und jetzt folgt für nix der tag
mit meiner kollegin konstanzer après ski
bis dahin tschüss
[Musik]